moore
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants notre petit nuage
on amène ce soir un grand artiste
nour le gotha patron paul choses
verrouillées
mais trois hommes font ragona
ducasse rond
l'ours
à vos souhaits m nounours bon le seul
humain jetés sans faire le portrait de
tonia un grenelle la pom pom pom poms
poms poms poms poms propos pas tant que
blues
couvrez moi les gens dont je suis très
choquée bourg je le sais les petits de
du départ à ses bras de tout ses
accessoires dans magic valley c'est ma
droite peinture nicolas tu peux regarder
[Musique]
tu paies je fais de la peinture dans ce
que tu en as des affaires de ma toile
twitter
ouais sur la chaîne hbo
je veux exécuté ce soir le portrait de
patronne heures ce sera une oeuvre par
nicolas si on voit ça et moi une autre
qu'est-ce que je tiens toi pas preneur
tu ne bouges pas tu t'assois là tu
regardes vers latins non mon petit on
regarder plutôt de l'autre côté et
surtout ne riez pas mais l'espagne où
nicolas apporter aux roses à votre sort
voilà m
on
attention je pas mais pas à chaud voilà
la question
j'exécute là à toi de jouer
mouss
hop hop un show
la roche rouge feu rouge sera
l'accouchement et flancs du vertendre du
vert gazon à pradelles lafleur 3
ça vient je le prends urgent en
découlant
long de la vie
shire des fiançailles voilà
il faut laisser sécher
[Musique]
ce pont n'est ce pas faisant front
oui c'est beau mais c'est pas fini nous
finirons tom je laisse toutes mes
affaires
ne touchez pas aux touchera pas cbre
amis et on va se coucher tout seul pas
nui no mad men ottoman
non
oh
[Musique]
au
[Applaudissements]
bonne nuit les petits amis pas trop ce
que je suis heureux j'ai fait un superbe
portrait de pape ronald bravo nounours
tu as tous les dons allons en route car
il est tard haute à demain bonne nuit
fais de pauvres
[Applaudissements]
oh
à
e
m